good morning believe nation my name is
Evan Carmichael my one word is believe
and I believe that entrepreneurs are
going to solve all of the world's major
problems so to help you on your journey
today we're going to learn how to build
self-discipline over to you Terry Crews
[Music]
the thing about self-discipline is that
it is necessary for everything you do in
your life you have to be self-discipline
it discipline comes from somewhere else
it's very very hard to remain consistent
because you tend to resist as well
because I see trainers and they're in
the gym with people and you know the guy
or girl that they're working out paints
their workout hates it
because the discipline is coming from
somewhere else you it's something that
you dread every time you go in you don't
really want to do it it's like oh but oh
no my trainers here he's about to you
know beat me up and make me feel crazy
well the truth is every trainer should
work his way out of your life anybody
who is working you out your teachers
your trainers your people they have to
train you to get out of your life so you
can go ahead do your own workout do your
own thing practice self-discipline
successful people have self-discipline
but you have to make sure you're
focusing on the right things you can
only force yourself to do something that
you don't like for so long until you
quit and so I think too many people have
the wrong holes too many people don't
have the self-awareness to know what
they really should be doing and have a
strong enough why'd to keep forcing them
to do it a lot of people who become
entrepreneurs start a business because
they look at the top hundred hottest
companies to start this year and that's
what they want to go and do because it's
going to make a lot of money where if
money is your only goal then we're going
to work out money yes is important but
there has to be something more important
that you're striving for if you look at
the top people or any field they have
deep passion for the work that they're
doing it because they love it so much it
helps enforce the self-discipline so the
best way that I found to stick to a
schedule to make sure that I am doing
the work that I want to do is one make
sure that I have a goal in mind that I
really feel passionate about but then to
create habits and a morning routine and
the schedules that support me achieving
that goal
so whatever goal you have make sure that
the work you're doing maps to you
creating that goal one of the hardest
things that I find is when I have a goal
and then I wake up on my schedules
thrown off and this is going to happen
in life right it's why I try to create a
no crisis business but your schedule
will at some points we thrown up you
better Drive somebody to work or you've
got to go to the hospital or some crisis
happens I find it really hard to get
back on schedule just like if you are
trying to stick to a diet and you have
that first chocolate bar
chances are the rest of your day is
going to get coldly thrown off and so if
you wake up and you set a morning
routine that sets you up for you
achieving your success you're more
likely to follow through so it's an
example if you want to learn how to be
fit you know look you want to learn how
to take care of yourself you wanna learn
how to be motivated if you're waking up
and watch some Terry Crews every morning
is the thing that you should be doing
because maybe your friends don't support
you maybe your parent leaders will
support you but you've got Terry you
watch him he's motivating you want to go
out and do something bigger for me it's
why I created the top ten series is why
I created a lot of the videos on my
channel because I wanted to be
surrounded with ultra successful people
that I may never meet and some people
have passed on so there's never a chance
to meet them but I feel like I'm hanging
around them and by watching their videos
in the morning not at five o'clock in
the evening and hoping to get motivated
for rest of the night in the morning to
start my day off so that I want to go
off and do something bigger so whatever
that feeling is you have your goal and
then whatever helps you get motivated
and get that feeling that you can create
on a consistent basis watching the video
talking to somebody reading a book
listen to a podcast whatever it is start
your day with that so you have the right
environment around
to help you maintain the discipline to
goal and achieve your goals so the
question today today is I'm curious what
is one thing that you're doing that
really helps you stay disciplined to
achieving your goals leave it down the
comments below
really curious to find out I also want
to give a quick shout out to our G from
Ally on consultants calm thank you so
much for picking up a couple of my books
your one word really really means a lot
to me and I hope you're enjoying the
view so thank you guys again for
watching I believe in you I hope we
continue to believe in yourself and
whatever your one word is much love and
I'll see you again tomorrow morning for
another shot events better
[Music]
so Tony one of the critics actually that
I once met said yeah Tony's techniques
they were great for about a year and a
half and then they wore off what do you
say to that folks real simple if you
don't work out you don't get up you
don't get a muscle right I always tell
people this is there's a daily practice
like priming if you don't do that if you
get up and you just have no discipline
whatsoever you get no value of anything
your diets don't work when you don't do
them exercise doesn't work when you
don't do them but most people have some
experiences that they want to shift and
once you shift those things your whole
life changes but life is constant growth
my life isn't here because I went to one
seminar one time and now my life is fit
for life I I workout I train my mind I
train my body it becomes a lifestyle
it's not just like you're depending upon
somebody else I'm going to become
somebody's guru I'm not here to give
them a gift I'm here them to open up
their own gifts and that's really what
my work is been I've never met a person
who is not successful that didn't have a
great amount of self-discipline within
their life self-discipline and being
able to perform and being able to keep
your life on schedule and being able to
keep commitments and promises and meet
deadlines is essential to success none
of us none of us can afford to have a
life that is controlled by someone else
or a life that is basically controlled
by our emotions I learned many years ago
that there are two kinds of people
there's the type of person who says I'm
going to wait till I feel like it before
I do it and then there's a person who
says I've got to do it so that I feel
like it one will never get anything done
because they're still waiting to feel
the moment to move and the other person
says no I need to move and then I will
begin to feel the moment Sonia
self-discipline is essential in your
life and in my life if we're going to
get things done so I have a challenge
for every one of you this weekend the
challenge is simple as you go through
your weekend and sometimes it's kind of
a hopefully an easier time of your week
ask yourself am i practicing
self-discipline in my life
am i doing the things that I should do
because I need to do them or am I kind
of waiting to feel the moment do like
our friends Nike say just do it when I
was in high school I must have been
maybe 16 or 17 years old and I went rock
climbing in El Dorado Canyon where I
near where I grew up in Boulder I've
been climbing about 3 or 4 years and I
wanted to do a climb called t2 now at
the time t2 is a relatively difficult
climb and I went at it with a kind of an
arrogant lack of preparation and I
hadn't prepared for being able to do
certain kinds of finger cracks I've got
I figure I'll figure that when I get
there and I also didn't pause and this
is I think about boldness and discipline
I didn't pause to really double smack
double check all my systems okay so I'm
on the fourth pitch I'm about 400 feet
above the ground I'm going across this
slanting crack system that I'd had
trouble that I started after on whether
my forearms started to engorge with
blood and lactic acid which means at
some point even if you're on a big hold
your hands are going to melt off okay
and I'm about to fall I'm 400 feet above
the ground but it should be okay because
there's protection I'm tied into the
rope I may take a fall but I'll get
caught for some reason and to this day I
still don't know why my brain triggered
that I should look at my knot and I
looked down at my not my knot had come
untied I had made the mistake of jive
never really thinking about the best nut
for certain types of situations and I
tied him with what's a bowline now the
advantage of a bowline is it's easy to
untie if you write the disadvantage of a
Boldin it is easy to untie it had come
untied as I kept moving across and it is
just hanging in my harness
I'm seconds away from falling only now I
will die I will die if I fall off my
forearms are melting and the not had
come untied and so I called down to my
partner I said why not comment I was he
going to do he can't do anything you
just watch me fall to my death and I
there was an old fixed Pete up in the
rock that would put there from the first
ascent an old soft iron Pete on and I
looked at it and I probably had 15 20
seconds before my hands put on that if
that maybe 10
I took a runner and I clipped it into
the Piton I clipped the Pete on into my
heart that runner into my harness and
just went please hold
and I let go and it helped I put in a
backup I grabbed the not be tied it went
to the legend convulsion I could I was
very calm at that moment I got to the
ledge I went into convulsive shaking I
was sick to my stomach for days because
of whatever happens chemically what I
learned from that is two things the
first is that when you're in an
unforgiving world gravity is unforgiving
it doesn't care it never takes a day off
ever and if you make one mistake it can
kill you if it's the wrong kind of
mistake what I learned is that sense of
yeah I want to do it interesting I want
to climb logs I want to be in Yosemite I
want to do things that get my adrenaline
going I but I need the discipline to
always do all the right preparation to
always think about the right nuts to
always be cross-checking my system so
that I can do those bold things and stay
alive in an unforgiving environment and
as you and I spoke about earlier today I
think that's the rest I think we are all
heading into an unforgiving environment
where we're going to have to be both
bold and disciplined the second thing I
learned what if that piton had not been
there we might not be here together it
was just by chance but that Pete tom was
right there and once you realize when
you rewind the tape of your own life is
that there are these crucial moments
where if the luck had gone the other way
you might have gotten killed and so what
you have to do is to always be X putting
those extra disciplines in place because
I was lucky to live and what I took from
that is I never want to have to be lucky
to live again I want to live because of
my discipline not because of my luck